TobiWan has been called the voice of Dota 2.
He’s one of the most well known and well
respected broadcast talents in professional
competitive gaming today.
He’s also one hell of a karaoke singer.
(Karaoke)
Hello there.
I’m Colin from theScore esports, and today,
we’re taking a look, or rather a listen,
at the best of Toby Dawson, AKA TobiWan.
Now I know you guys know TobiWan primarily
for Dota, but he actually got his start in
the Australian Call of Duty scene.
He’s also dabbled in CS:GO, and done PUBG
hosting and commentary as well.
Now before we get into those games guys, I
am going to give you what you came for, those
iconic Dota 2 TobiWan calls.
(Casting)
Now, I can’t be the only guy who got goosebumps
from hearing those calls again, can I?
Those are the iconic, serious, TobiWan Dota
2 calls, but we’d be doing the man a disservice
if we didn’t acknowledge his more meme-y,
kooky, wacky side.
And that’s what this next section is all
about.
(Karaoke)
(Casting)
Oh my god, it's a black hooooooooooooooooooooooooooole.
Hello.
My name's Toby.
TobiWan.
Would you like a Dota?
I could eat 9000 of these.
Over 9000.
My mama always said,  life is like a box of Dota.
You never know when you're going to get hooked.
I realize I put you on the spot, but they did have an over 10 kill advantage
Camera X, camera X.
It's a disaster.
Thank you so much, I want to put that on my FaceBook page.
(Casting)
Now guys, this video would not be complete
if we didn’t acknowledge the other games
that TobiWan has left his mark on.
He’s not just Dota 2 after all, as I said
in the intro, he’s done COD, he’s done
CS:GO, and he’s done PUBG as well.
And in true TobiWan fashion, he’s left us
with some hilarious one-liners from each one
of those.
(Casting)
Alright guys, that’s all we got for you
this week.
What was your favourite TobiWan call or moment?
And is there a player, a topic, or
team you want to see us cover in a future video?
If so, let me know in the comments below and
I will see you next week.